we got three good-looking guys in suits
here okay so the big do you not agree
well very dapper by the way the boys
dapper these boys are in Versace Gucci
like how slick did they look tonight
show up look like kids so the question
is guys I would imagine they didn't
understand every joke did you want to
keep it that way what did you say to
them when they asked you hey what is
this me and if they did ask your parents
your parents we are not all kids
everywhere yes let's say to everything I
say to adults I say to everyone who
asked me anything ask your parents
there's a movie like this and working
with great kids like this you know it is
raunchy that there's parenting involved
does it make you like wanna I don't know
if everybody has kissed does it make you
want to have more kids if you do already
does it make you want to have kids does
it scare you from parenting we get we
have kids and I look forward to a time
when they can do anything but Earl food
and crap on the floor which is where
we're at a day where they can have
meaningful emotional interactions with
me I'd prefer to have the good boys boys
than my little maniacs at this place
yeah I look for a yeah if my kids could
support me financially that would be
fantastic
the trombley's are very lucky family
Rolexes we ask the kids to do a Seth
impression well what would you guys
think they went for who do you think did
it best do you guys do a set and not for
free yeah in special events weddings
funerals stuff like that I heard the
movie came a lot from real-life
experiences did you guys throw in any of
your own cuz there was some improv right
we spent every experience from our
childhood on super bad yeah
pulling from others know the tube is
like I think the emotional story of like
you know realizing around when you're 12
that maybe the kids you were friends
with up until that point aren't gonna be
the kids that you continue to be friends
with your whole life yeah we very much
experience that and you know where the
we're each other's new friends
so there's what's a loser's I don't hang
out with anymore that's what this movies
about speaking of if I may I have to ask
you this next month 20th anniversary of
the premiere freaks and geeks what do
you remember about that oh that just
makes me want to thanks for that
fantastic Jacob Tremblay was 20 years
away from being bored yeah great I don't
know I didn't know that so that's a
horribly depressing fact thank you very
last for you guys you've now done kids
you did superb at high school okay you
know let me rephrase in today's day and
age you've done this great kids movie
you've done super bad thank you for that
Seth what's next a movie set in college
or what you guys want to know something
very senior citizen babe baby boomers
are aging it's a very profitable market
yeah